mesdames messieurs bonsoir depuis
quelques minutes vous voyez le monial
déployer ses fast path to protocolaire
avec le défilé de cette équipe qui
participe à cette coupe du monde et dans
40 minutes très précisément va s'ouvrir
la compétition proprement dite avec le
premier match pologne allemagne premier
match retransmis en direct sur notre
chaîne à partir de 19h50 c'est la raison
pour laquelle vous voyez ce journal est
avancé que les informations régionales
sont super x pardon à nos amis 10h les
tricolores ne se prépare au match de
demain un match qui verra finalement la
participation de diou
après une nuit de réflexion michel
hidalgo la préférait finalement aux
monégasques petit cette coupe du monde
va donc débuter au moment et au milieu
d'un exceptionnel déploiement de mesures
de sécurité elle sera l'occasion d'un
formidable coup de projecteur donné par
la presse sur la situation intérieure de
l'argentine
les protestations se multiplient parfois
un petit peu désordonné ou même
franchement dévié de leur bus d'origine
c'est le cas de la manifestation qui
s'est déroulée hier soir à dijon
manifestations organisées comme à paris
par le comité de politique du mundial
2000 personnes environ mais qui a
dégénéré une cinquantaine de casseurs
s'en sont pris aux vitrines du centre de
la ville
ils ont pillé plusieurs magasins
renversé des voitures et tenté de mettre
le feu à une banque
tout à l'heure une quarantaine de
commerçants dijonnais ont demandé la
démission du préfet de la côte d'or
il lui reproche d'avoir donné trop tard
aux gendarmes mobiles l'ordre de charger
il ya aussi les protestations plus
classiques comme celle du centriste
bernard stasi qui regrette le silence du
gouvernement une mise en garde du
gouvernement at il dit sur europe 1
aurais-tu quelques chances d'être prises
en considération enfin il ya des
manifestations plus insolites
ainsi celle de ses deux bagagistes de
solides qui est d'un grand hôtel
parisien
j'avais refusé il ya quelques jours de
porter les bagages de militaires
argentins eh bien ces trois employés
l'hôtel meurice ont reçu ce matin leur
l'aide des licences
il n'était pas question pour nous de ne
pas servir un client particulier que ce
soit pour sa race sa religion sa couleur
politique ou quoi à partir du moment où
nous avons des militaires argentins qui
sont un conte des tortionnaires puisque
c'était un très haut niveau
nous pouvions pas admettre qu'une
délégation non officiels arrivent en
france par trouve pratiquement quand
c'est une provocation pour nous donc
nous avons refusé de leur monter les
bagages et de les servir
voilà l es trois employés redemande leur
réintégration
voilà pour l'aspect politique de ce
dossier argentine
le sport c'est donc pour toutes à leurs
20 heures sur un thème des jeux ratés
ville frites baumgartner est mort
aujourd'hui à paris monsieur baumgartner
avait 76 ans il était gouverneur
honoraire de la banque de france
c'était surtout un ancien ministre des
finances au tout début de la vème
république
tout de suite après antoine pinay et il
avait à l'époque pour ce fait à des tas
un homme politique qui ait fait son
chemin
valéry giscard d'estaing le chef de
l'état au portugal c'est confirmé le
président giscard d'estaing sera là bas
du 19 au 22 juillet ce sera la première
visite d'un président français depuis
emile loubet il y a trois quarts de
siècle conseil restreint à l'elysée sur
le développement des collectivités
locales premier débat au sénat le 20
juin les parlementaires rpr ceux du
bureau du groupe en tout cas reçu tout à
l'heure à déjeuner par valéry giscard
d'estaing pas de commentaires à la
sortie de la part du président du groupe
claude labbé françois mitterrand à
france inter ce matin le programme
commun de gouvernement est forclos ans à
mitterrand qui par ailleurs a critiqué
le gouvernement pour sa position au
chabat il a donné un mauvais spectacle
dans cette affaire at il dit et puis le
leader socialiste l'a répété dans
l'unité d'aujourd'hui aussi précisément
deux pièces essentielles que notre
envoyé spécial au zaïre françois cornet
est en mesure ce soir de nous fournit
d'abord l'interview du colonel erulin
c'est le patron des paras français au
chabat et c'est la première fois qu'il
répond à un journaliste sur ses
accusations lancées sur antenne 2 il y a
dix jours à l'occasion d'un dossier de
l'écran par le communiste rené andrieu
rené andrieu l'accusé d'avoir pratiqué
la torture en algérie par exemple sur le
militant henri alleg
ce qui a pu être dit quant à mon cas
personnel je trouve qu'on a déjà
enfin j'ai déjà dit ce que j'en pensais
on en a assez parlé c'est pour le moins
inopportun de l'attaqué des gens dans
ces circonstances officiellement mon
colonel que faites-vous maintenant à
lubumbashi
eh bien nous ont passé huit jours de
l'opération pénible et fatigante et je
suis sûr au repos de façon essaimé
hommes souffler un peu et d'entretenir
mon matériel est ce que vous allez
maintenant rentrer sur calvi ou rester
sur place pour assurer la sécurité des
européens
il ya du fait même de notre présence ici
nous assurons indirectement la sécurité
des européens
maintenant mon avenir il dépend du
gouvernement et je n'ai encore aucune
directive concernant les prochains jours
ou les prochaines semaines
que pensez vous de la situation sur le
plan militaire côté rebellion au chabat
et côté sécurité des troupes zaïroise
est bien coté rébellion enfin je vous
parlerais de kolwezi que je connais j'ai
laissé à kolwezi calme avec une sécurité
que jacques rey
établie jusqu'à une quinzaine de
kilomètres sur les pourtours on peut
dire que la ville n'est pas menacée j'ai
encore actuellement un détachement assez
important là-bas et les renseignements
que j'ai font état d'une situation
parfaitement calme et d'une population
qui reprend petit à petit goût à la vie
et recommencent à nettoyer la ville et à
reprendre les activités et quand vous
allez retirer vos troupes
que se passera-t-il selon vous bien là
tout dépendra du contexte mais je pense
que quand on me demandera de retirer
mais les hommes de là bas il y aura ou
quelqu'un pour prendre le relais ou une
situation telle qu on puisse faire tirer
sans danger et bien précisément voici un
élément de réponse c'est luigi ringot le
ministère et d'autres enchères qui
viennent déclaré devant la commission
des affaires étrangères à l'assemblée
donc qu'un contingent africain pourrait
se rendre aux ailleurs la semaine
prochaine et donc le 2e rep serait ainsi
rapatrier le sénégal de son côté
n'exclut pas d'envoyer un contingent
tout cas l'envoi de forces armées là-bas
oseille
vous savez que l'essentiel des paras
français trois compagnies sur quatre a
maintenant quitté koh loisy pour le
monde bachy les européennes là-bas
considère que la présence militaire des
français et des belges est indispensable
pour leurs garanties et leur sécurité
ils sont bien sûr très traumatisée par
ce qui s'est passé à kolwezi co loisy
qui jour après jour reprend doucement
trop hâtives
ces blessés qui sont débarqués des
transall français sont des civils ils
ont été touchés durant la prise et
l'occupation de kolwezi hospitalisé
depuis dans la cité minière
ils ont été rapatriés sur le boom bachy
les médecins blanc ou noir ont quitté la
ville de la peur seuls trois
généralistes zaïrois sont restés à
l'hôpital de collo asie mais ils ne sont
plus en nombre suffisant pour s'occuper
des malades et des blessés
on attend l'arrivée au chabab d'une
antenne chirurgicale française qui
devrait être implanté dans les prochains
jours
ako loisy depuis dimanche dernier trois
compagnies et le pc logistique du 2e
régiment étranger de parachutistes
environ 750 hommes d'ivoire à lubumbashi
en attendant de rentrer sur sol en aura
encore un quart des forces du 2e rep une
compagnie renforcée de 150 hommes se
trouvaient toujours mercredi à kolwezi
à l'heure où nous enregistrons ce
commentaire le 31 mai tout est calme au
chabat les troupes françaises sont au
repos
les paras belges se met en place à
kipushi le long de la frontière
gambienne et à likasi pour assurer la
protection des européens un premier
détachement de commando marocain est
arrivé sur place il attend à lubumbashi
l'ordre de relever les troupes
françaises actualité sociale maintenant
des mouvements de grèves chez renault à
cléon et à flins plusieurs centaines
d'ouvriers ont entamé un mouvement de
grève bouchon ceux qui entravent le
travail des non-grévistes d'un mouvement
à suivre comme tout ce qui vient de chez
renault chez boussac
la cfdt propose l'occupation de
certaines usines du groupe
et puis dans les services publics
quelques grève parisienne à la sncf et à
la rapt est plr ratp car dans la plus
importante restant sur tout le
territoire cette fois ci celle des
gaziers et électriciens cgt et cfdt
une grève suivie à 50% mais la direction
à 75 % disent les syndicats grève de
protestation contre le projet de loi du
ministre de l'industrie andré giraud un
projet relatif aux économies d'énergie
et à l'utilisation de la chaleur cela
porterait atteinte à la nationalisation
de ce j ai dit le syndicat vu de
l'extérieur une centrale nucléaire
produit de l'électricité
mais en fait le coeur atomique ne
fabrique lui que de la chaleur
celle ci sous forme de vapeur d'eau fait
tourner et l'alternateur et pour obtenir
un bon fonctionnement de l'ensemble il
faut refroidir avec de l'eau c'est cette
eau chauffée qui est rejetée
actuellement comme déchets du coup
l'énergie totale produite par la
centrale devient 30 % d'électricité et
70% de rejet d'eau chaude
ce principe est vrai pour le nucléaire
mais également pour toute installation
industrielle produisant de l'électricité
le projet de loi du gouvernement
consiste à rendre intéressante la
récupération de la chaleur à 6 gaspiller
les syndicats d'edf s'oppose à l'actuel
formulation du texte du projet de loi
nous sommes pour les économies d'énergie
nous sommes contre les gaspillages
d'énergie est précisément la loi qui est
proposé à l'assemblée nationale
conduirait à des gaspillages en portant
atteinte à l'unité de production
d'électricité que possède électricité de
france depuis 1946 est ce que
j'entendais par gaspillage gaspillage en
ce sens qu'il n'y aurait plus la
coordination qui est souhaitable dans le
domaine énergétique
or ce n'est pas en retirant à
electricité de france
une partie de la production
d'électricité on peut réduire les
gaspillages
est ce qu'il y aura d'autres coupures de
courant prochainement et bien tout
dépend de l'attitude des députés à
l'assemblée nationale nous avons prévu
une manifestation le 8 place des
invalides
mais évidemment tout dépend du
développement de la discussion à
l'assemblée
vous avez entendu ce qu'ont dit les
syndicalistes si les députés n'agissent
pas conformément à leurs voeux il n'y
aura il y aura de nouveaux grève avec
coupure de courant le 8 juin
moi je suis journée scientifique mais je
trouve quand même ça bizarre du point de
vue politique c'est le parlement qui
doit décider il me semble qu'il y avait
un autre rôle enfin bref où et comment
c'est difficile d'innover en france même
dans un domaine aussi vital que celui
des économies d'énergie
je sais pas ce que va devenir ce projet
de loi en discussion au parlement mais
ce que je souhaite pour l'avenir
énergétique de la france c'est que ce
gaspillage insensé de chaleur cette
énorme quantité de chaleur qui éviterait
des importations de millions de tonnes
de pétrole s'arrête même si pour cela
edf doit partager son pouvoir sur les
centrales nucléaires une vingt 120
arbres en place hubert beuve-méry au
conseil d'administration de l'aef et
monsieur beuve méry qui avait
démissionné pour protester contre les
conditions de la nomination du nouveau
président la sp roger bouzinac et puis
il nous faut revenir sur le projet de
loi adopté hier par le conseil des
ministres et qui tente et qui tend
plutôt à favoriser l'achat d'actions en
bourse par les petits épargnants pour
aider les entreprises
vous êtes nombreux à nous poser des
questions très pratiques sur les
conditions et l'intérêt de l'opération
est bien philippe sassier va essayer de
nous répondre
les français n'aiment pas la bourse si
on les comprend si vous avez acheté pour
100 francs d'actions 1964 et bien c'est
100 francs jour d'hui ne représente
guère que 30 francs vote aux pentes
votre portefeuille a fondu pendant trop
longtemps la bourse était mal aimé ce
sont d'autres placements immobiliers
notamment qui ont bénéficié des
avantages fiscaux coffret le
gouvernement du reste regardez comment
les français placent leur argent l'an
passé en 1977
l'épargné des français et les emprunts
qu'ils ont fait pour faire des
placements ont représenté le chiffre
énorme de 340 2 milliards un chiffre que
l'on peut tout à fait comparé au budget
de l'état
sur ce total 110 milliards ont été
investis dans l'immobilier 47 milliards
ont pris le chemin des caisses d'epargne
19 ont été placés dans l'épargné
logement est un peu plus de neuf
seulement dans la bourse et ce dernier
chiffre que le gouvernement voudrait
voir remonter voudrait voir redresser et
ceci en accordant à la bourse des
avantages fiscaux alors de combien et
bien chaque année vous pourrez déduire
quand vous aurez acheté des actions 5000
francs de vos revenus à ses 5000 francs
s'ajouteront cinq cents francs par
enfant à charge et 1000 francs à partir
du troisième c'est à dire qu'une famille
de trois enfants pourra déduire chaque
année 7000 francs de ses revenus
maintenant comment eh bien il faudra que
chaque année vous achetiez davantage
d'actions que vous en vendez par exemple
si vous achetez pour 5000 francs
d'actions cette année vous pourrez
déduire
revenue 5000 francs mais si l'an
prochain vous en revendre et pour 3000
points de ses actions il faudra
réincorporer sur votre feuille d'impôts
3000 francs revanche si vous continuer
d'acheter chaque année davantage
d'actions la déduction est toujours
possible
enfin un troisième question est-ce qu'il
peut qu'avoir un cumul entre les
différents abattements fiscaux qui sont
autorisés par la loi
et bien la réponse est oui c'est à dire
que vous pouvez avoir ces déductions de
5000 francs qui s'ajoutent aux
déductions qui sont permises dans ce que
vous avez une assurance vie et aux
déductions qui sont permises élaguer
également lorsque vous avez emprunté
pour acheter votre votre votre
habitation principale
par conséquent vous pouvez cumuler ces
trois abattements fiscaux et grâce à ces
mesures le gouvernement espère bien que
environ un million de français
supplémentaires vont venir s'intéresser
à la bourse
merci philippe seta viana d'attentats la
violente explosion qui a détruit dans la
nuit de mardi à mercredi
les conduites aérienne du gaz de france
alfortville était bien imputables à un
acte volontaire mais l'attentât n'était
pas signé quatorze cadavres de chevaux
dans un wagon c'est la macabre
découverte qu'ont faite hier les
employés la sncf en gare de beauvais
contrairement au règlement les chemins
de fer les normes d'aération n'ont pas
été respectées
les quatorze chevaux étaient destinés à
l'abattoir mais leur faim était vraiment
atroce et puis l approche des vacances
une bonne nouvelle ce qu'ils vont se
rendre en espagne par la route en
meilleure condition de transborder les
voir pourquoi une bonne nouvelle un mois
des vacances l'inauguration ce matin des
49 km qui manquait à l'autoroute catalan
non seulement ce dernier tronçon fait
sauter le célèbre bouchon de la
frontière espagnole
mais il permet de relier directement
l'espagne à tous les pays d'europe
le prix de ses 49 km a été fixé à 9
francs soit 115 francs de paris à la
frontière mais le ministre le theule n'a
pas caché que de nouvelles augmentations
de péages étaient à prévoir
non en fait rien ne prouve encore que
l'explosion qui a fait sauter dans la
nuit de mardi à mercredi les conduites
de l' usine à gaz d'alfortville soit
d'origine criminelle
l'attentât est peut être une hypothèse
plausible mais aucune organisation ne
s'est manifesté et le gaz de france ne
se connaît pas d'ennemi par chance les
quatre explosions n'ont fait aucune
victime mais elles ont provoqué de gros
dégâts matériels
cette gigantesque torchère de plusieurs
dizaines de mètres de haut a illuminé le
ciel toute la nuit
il faudra des semaines de travail pour
remettre l'usiné en marche une tonne et
demie d'explosifs et pourtant
l'explosion a fait pschitt
décidément les anglais n'arrivent pas à
se débarrasser de l'épave du pétrolier
grec qui depuis un mois déverse son
pétrole sur les côtes de la manche ce
dernier échec retentissant a soulevé un
concert de critiques à l'égard du
gouvernement
en attendant chômeurs et bénévoles
continue de nettoyer les plages des deux
côtés de la manche
on n'a encore rien trouvé de mieux que
le souhait l'appel pour lutter contre la
marée noire
sport maintenant tennis d'abord toujours
beaucoup de monde et de soleil pour la
4e journée des internationaux de france
assez pour le cliché mais il ya surtout
deux surprises de taille
l'élimination de l'un des favoris
l'italien adriano panatta devant
l'américain borowiak et puis surtout en
ce moment la situation très
inconfortable de l'un des deux grands
favoris l'argentin guillermo vilas
racing paris va nous donner des
nouvelles du match de vilas contre un
jeune inconnu
martin hier mobile à ce qu'ils étaient
menés tout à l'heure l'argentin
guillermo villas sont dans du court
dernier vainqueur de roland garros est
en grande difficulté contre l'américaine
marcy et doit disputer un 5e set
ce même narre-t-il qui l'avait battu à
wimbledon l'an troisième martina joueur
de 20 ans sont complexes n'hésite pas à
monter au filet il a toute évidence bien
que maladroit service premier set
remporté par villa 6 2e et 3e sets
martin
ce soit si ce quatrième set 6-2 oublie
date la cinquième manche
comment ces villages parce qu'au nord
c'est hors des places et 3e joueur
mondial
roland garros va nous réserver des
surprises car les têtes de série sans
doute fatigué cela est sans doute dû à
un excès des coûts afférents au tennis
ou dire beaucoup d'argent game lui en ce
moment un autre match entre deux grands
espoirs du tennis français noah contre
morton les résultats de ces deux matches
dans notre vie un journal en cyclisme
quatrième étape du dauphiné libéré avec
la victoire du belge jacques martin il
s'appelle comme ça
au classement général maurice le
guilloux est toujours leader j'avais
hâte hier c'est aujourd'hui à longchamp
la combinaison gagnante et le 5 le 3 et
le 10 les rapports dans l'ordre 4243 150
dans un ordre différent 837 francs
le bulletin de la météo maintenant avec
tout d'abord une statistique le mois de
mai qui vient de s'écouler a été le
moins ensoleillé depuis près d'un demi
siècle sur toute la france le temps
était chaud aujourd'hui ensoleillé sur
tout le pays avec des orages un peu
partout
les températures étaient en hausse
demain après les brumes matinales le
temps restera beau du soleil avec
quelques passages nuageux en bretagne et
puis des orages sur la moitié sudiste en
fin de soirée vers 23h20 c'est patrick
lecocq qui vous présentera le journal
encore quelques minutes de patience et à
20h le premier match de la coupe du
monde allemagne pologne je vous souhaite
une excellente soirée
demain rendez vous à 20h au revoir